I finished a book in the early part of
2007 for publication in October,
2007 on current and national affairs,
um,
because I think that the most important
overarching thing going on is that the
United States has to again become the
land of opportunity and the land and the
place that operates according to
principles.
So it's called America the principled
six opportunities for becoming a can do
nation once again.
And so those six opportunities seem to
me to be the most important issues.
One is how do we secure our future?
And security isn't simply a matter of
watchdogs at airports.
It's a matter of economic security.
That's how we keep jobs in the United
States for Americans.
That's how we ensure that we have the
technology to make us safe.
And that requires investments in
innovation and it requires open minds.
So the life sciences are so important.
And yet,
um,
they have been so discredited by an
administration that has not cared about
science.
We're not doing enough to educate people
in the US in science and math,
which are so important to our future.
Most of the engineering and science
degrees being given in the United States
today,
advanced degrees,
phds are going to foreign nationals or
people of foreign origins and as far as
I'm concerned,
they're welcome here,
but I would also like to see our young
people get those degrees.
So that's,
uh,
that's the first challenge.
I'm very concerned about the
disappearing middle class and the
problems of balancing work and family
that women have.
So pursuing happiness was something
that's written into our earliest
origins,
life,
liberty and the pursuit of happiness and
awful lot of people aren't happy because
they don't have healthcare because they
have to take two jobs.
They don't,
they're worried about their children.
So that's an important issue.
Clearly the war in Iraq as an important
issue currently,
but it's part of a larger problem of how
do we engage with the world.
Is our form of engagement only saber
rattling or are we making those
grassroots investments in the economic
development of other countries and the
development of their leaders so that we
have more allies and friends around the
world.
That's a major challenge.
We are not liked in many parts of the
world.
Well actually there's a gap between
liking Americans as a people and liking
the American government.
Many more people like Americans than
like the American government.
We have an speaking of government.
We have a problem with respect for
government.
In fact,
in recent years people have discredited
government because so many government
officials have done things that are
ethically challenged to put it in a
positive way,
but a lot of Washington was under
indictment for awhile.
So if we don't restore respect for
government,
I'm sick of politicians running against
government.
I'm running for this office because I
believe that we shouldn't have these
offices.
It's ridiculous.
So we need respect.
So the good people run for office in
turn,
they appoint competent people and they
care about how well government is run.
It's an.
It's a traditional American principle to
say that government is best,
which governs least,
but frankly it can't govern least unless
it governs better because it's much more
costly to have a disaster like Hurricane
Katrina than it would have been to
invest in the levees in New Orleans in
the first place.
And finally,
I think we need a spirit of service.
The partisan divides in the partisan
ugliness and America has plagued us if
we spend so much time arguing with each
other while fighting wars that we can't
possibly win and probably shouldn't have
been in in the first place,
then we will never heal this nation.
We need things that bring us together
across partisan divides as well as
divides of race or age or or urban
versus rural,
and I think community service and the
generosity of American philanthropy or
things that can unite us.
Again.
So those are the themes that I've been
writing about.
Those are the things that I want on the
agenda for the presidential election in
2008.
Those are the things in the news that
bother me the most,
but also inspire me to think about
solutions.